they show no sign of ending and the
regime cannot hide the protests which
are continuing to escalate across the
country
despite cutting internet access these
images made their way onto social media
they show Oil Workers at Key refineries
now joining in the demonstrations the
footage offers a window on a nation
convulsing with anger
I think they're very symbolic uh
certainly because it will remind people
of what happened in 1978 when the Oil
Workers came out in in strike in favor
of the Revolution
but obviously it will also hurt the um
the the income and revenue of the state
the demonstrations have now been going
on for weeks they were triggered by the
death in custody of 22 year old Iranian
kurd Masa amini she'd been arrested for
allegedly not covering her hair properly
by the feared morality police
protests that erupted are in the main
led by women and their Defiance is
everywhere
many now walking the streets
rebelliously without a hijab in this
clip motorists can be heard honking
their supports
at universities women call openly for
regime change
the girls that are out on the streets or
have been filmed inside their schools in
the uh open areas have consistently been
calling out death to the dictator which
is very unusual to hear and which is of
course referring to the supreme leader
of Iran and the really driving force of
the of these protests is the slogan
women life liberty
[Applause]
[Music]
there are signs the Crackdown is
becoming more brutal but the regime is
struggling to cope with this women-led
protest
[Applause]
the fact that they see their uh Keen
killed on the streets and still coming
out means that they have no fear at the
moment of course they could be repressed
but I don't think their movement will
come timing
and the protesters chance of death to
tyranny corruption and oppression will
not be easily silenced
Alex Rossi Sky News